organic farming will be the focus of the
agriculture and Fisheries Council in
Brussels on Monday March the 16th the
ongoing proposal aims to review the
existing legislation on organic
production and labeling of organic
products the goals are mutter
strengthened the development of organic
production in the EU guarantee fair
competition for farmers and improve
consumer confidence in organic products
ministers are expected to give guidance
on sensitive issues such as the presence
of pesticides as well as other forbidden
substances in organic products they will
also debate the import regime and the
control systems of organic products
dairy will also be high on the
minister's agenda as the milk quota
system that has governed the EU market
for over three decades draws to an end
in March 2015 milk quotas have
conditioned the activity of an entire
generation of dairy farmers most of whom
have never produced in an unlimited
environment as a result in some weeks
the EU milk sector will be more
market-oriented this will bring about
changes for dairy producers in a context
of price volatility and market
fluctuation the Commission will brief
ministers on the dairy sector state of
play as well as on current and upcoming
measures ministers will also hold a
debate on the implementation and
simplification of the Common
Agricultural Policy otherwise known as
cap finally the council will be briefed
on animal welfare of furred animals
following a broadcast by Dutch TV and
the publication of a report by an animal
rights organization the Netherlands
would like to address the issue at
council level to prevent products
involving animal welfare mal practices
from entering the EU market